what's on your like kind of risk map in
terms of ways out for Putin is it Trump
being reelected
I can't see Trump being re-elected
because I think he's too mired and filth
the problem really DeSantis could make
it but this answers is good on Ukraine
I'm I'm I'm having less nightmares about
Trump
um which is sweet
um so
I think that
that the the the the serious danger is
that Western politicians are used to
trading and dealing and compromising and
that's kind of in their DNA
and we're dealing with uh with Russian
fascism
um by the way Putin didn't used to be
quite as fascistic as he is now so he's
there's something uh there's something
around about the the start of covid
where he he goes into a darker place
so when I met him in 2014 he was subtle
and sensitive enough to say oh here's an
irritating prick from the BBC Panorama
show you know what I'm going to do is
I'm gonna I'm gonna
treat him as if I'm a Democratic
president which he was very good at it
sounds like he was very
you know
well done president like he gave a long
and boring and fundamentally absolutely
dishonest answer but he gave me an
answer so I couldn't say he didn't
answer me
um and that guy
who has so he's become more
nationalistic it may be because he
thinks he's dying in which case and by
the way he may be wrong about thinking
he is dying but if he thinks he's dying
then he's got to move quickly because
he's run out of Road
but but I I feel that
the
um
the best way of ending this is to give
the ukrainians a heavy metal so that
Putin's War has failed
and then the Russian people the
oligarchs
some of the secret policemen around him
think
this guy is useless let's get rid of him
and the moment that sets in then
um
then that's not good news when a Russian
leader loses a war
their longevity
is limited
Leone from London gets the last question
which is about Iran so so of course um
Putin
which is
um firstly for death to America death uh
so is is
um will will Putin be able to get around
on side yeah
John will
um he'd be able to get Iran on side and
what would be the impact if he does a
bit more broadly will his famous kind of
state craft you know get him out of the
mess that he's made for himself no
um Iran is
I mean they're just mucking around I
think um they're just being
the American Stone line Putin so
um we're friends but but essentially if
you're a clever Russian
you're an oligarch
you used to park your yacht and Sandra
pay
you send your bastards to Eaton you
um you park your money in the city of
London
duh and now you can fly all the way to
Pyongyang
you can go to Eritrea and you can go to
Tehran
and by the way the nightclub scene in
Tehran is not what it used to be so so I
think that this is
pathetic attempt by Putin to make his
disasters look less bad
and I don't think it's going to work
um and so I'm not very worried about
that I'm far more worried about the
failure
or if people like Schultz
persist in trying to
um
pressure and weaken ukrainians for a
short-term and unlovely and unjust peace
that gives Putin more time in power
he'll come back there will be more war
and the Chinese are watching
so I mean I'm
um
I see this as 39.45
we've got to defeat these people because
they're evil
full stop